Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic, la gravité selon Newton.
Pourquoi une pomme tombe-t-elle d'un arbre, vers le bas ?
Et pourquoi la Lune tourne-t-elle autour de la Terre ?
Au 17e siècle, le mathématicien et physicien Isaac Newtow répond à ces deux questions par une seule réponse :
La gravitation.
Qu'est-ce que la gravitation ?
Dans l'univers, tous les corps ayant une masse s'attirent entres eux
Par exemple, la Lune attire la Terre et la Terre attire la Lune.
Maintenant imaginons un premier objet "A" et un second objet "B" séparés par une certaine distance...
Par la gravitation, ces deux objets s'attirent entre eux.
Ainsi "A" va se rapprocher de "B", et "B" va se rapprocher de "A"
Si "A" était plus massif, alors la force d'attraction serait plus grande.
Et à l'inverse, si "A" était moins massif, alors la force d'attraction serait plus faible.
Cela vaut également pour "B"
Ensuite, si les deux corps étaient plus distants, la force d'attraction serait plus faible.
Et s'ils étaient plus proches, la force d'attraction serait plus forte.
Ainsi, l'attraction gravitationnelle d'un objet sur un autre perd son influence lorsque les deux objets sont très éloignés.
Prenons maintenant l'exemple de la pomme. La pomme possède une certaine masse et la Terre également.
Donc la pomme attire la Terre, et inversement la Terre attire la pomme.
C'est pour ça que la pomme et la Terre vont se rapprocher mutuellement, jusqu'à ce que la pomme touche le sol.
Maintenant, imaginons que l'on lance la pomme dans une direction avec une certaine vitesse...
Comme tout à l'heure, la pomme va être attirée vers la Terre, mais elle va également se diriger dans la direction dans laquelle on l'a lancée, en fonction de sa vitesse.
Plus la vitesse augmente plus la pomme tombe loin.
Si maintenant on pouvait lancer la pomme avec une vitesse assez élevée, on se rend compte que cette vitesse compenserait l'attraction gravitationnelle, et que la pomme ne tomberait jamais sur Terre.
C'est ce qui se passe pour la Lune, et c'est pour ça que la Lune tourne autour de la Terre, ou encore que le Terre tourne autour du Soleil.